started again I just wanted to remind
you where we left off so we just
finished covering the some Czech
protocol and this allows approver and
verifier to compute the sum of an l
variate polynomials evaluations overall
to to the l boolean inputs and the
verifiers runtime is order D times L
where D is the maximum degree of the
polynomial in each variable plus the
time to require to evaluate that
polynomial G at a single point and we
can compare this like one last time to
the time required to just solve the
problem in the first place
and that time would is at least 2 to the
L times the time required to evaluate G
at one point that's the the function
we're trying to compute here is summing
G's evaluations at 2 to the L inputs it
basically turns 2 to the L evaluations
of G as far as the verifiers runtime
goes down to one evaluation of G all
right so now we're going to see why this
protocol is so useful so I'm going to
give an interactive proof for a problem
called sharp set alright so in this
problem the input is a boolean formula
let me call it fee we're going to let s
denote its size and end the number of
variables so boolean formula is just its
inputs are 0 one value and then the
formula consists of an lor and not gates
and formula just means each each gate
has fan-out one right so each gate has 1
wire coming out of it and so so this
boolean formula just computes you know
some function of the inputs by applying
these logic gates to the universe
so the
because the diagram supporters yeah well
when each it's a formula so each gate
has been out one so like even the inputs
canola oh I see yeah it could be other
questions about boolean formulas so
it'll be important that each K does spin
out one but this is just a picture it's
not don't over over fit to the picture
x3 could also be fed into another okay
so the goal is to count the number of
satisfying assignments of the formula
that is the number of assignments that
cause the formula to evaluate to true so
put another way if we view the formula
as a function mapping n bits you know 0
1 to the N 2 bits 0 1 where we're
interpreting 0 as false and 1 is true
then we're just summing up these values
the formulas values on all boolean
inputs
it's probably sense
okay so that is our goal and this should
kind of look a little familiar because
we're summing up some functions values
overall boolean inputs see something
like that recently so before I tell you
how to solve it let me just make sure
everyone is clear about what I mean by
this being a zero one valued function so
let me just evaluate this formula on a
certain zero one value input so this is
a not gate so not of zero is one right
not just in the gates the you know false
to true and true to false and then this
is an end gate so if you feed to true
values in to end it evaluates to true or
1 and this is an or gate so or of true
and false is true and then the output of
the formula is is true in this case okay
so we want to sum up the zero one valued
function on all all boolean inputs and
this is how we do it we just apply the
sum check protocol to an extension of
this formula
so that is we let G be any polynomial
such that if you feed into G a boolean
value it spits out exactly what fee
spits out on that value protocol lets us
sum all of that up
so hopefully if some checks seemed
esoteric originally why would you want
to sum up the evaluations of some
polynomial on a bunch of inputs now it
seems less subtle all right so why
aren't we done like why don't we just
move on to the next application and the
answer is we need some properties out of
this polynomial G so firstly in the
final round of the subject protocol the
verifier has to evaluate the polynomial
at a randomly chosen input so we better
choose an extension G of fee for which
the verifier can evaluate G efficiently
at a randomly chosen input and we need
more from G so we need it to be low
degree all right so to control the
soundness of the protocol to control the
provers runtime the length of the
messages and thereby the verifiers
runtime everything depends on G being
low degree if she had just huge huge
huge degree everything's going to go out
the window right so the next few minutes
are going to tell you how we can take
this formula fee and turn it into a
extension polynomial G
so the formula fee is not a polynomial
at all it's just a boolean formula
there's so I'm not sure your question is
quite well defined so we just have to
take this boolean formula formulas have
nothing do with polynomials and we have
to turn the formula into an extension
polynomial okay so you ready yeah
so that's what that's what the next few
slides are gonna be the extension
polynomial G was right yes so so the F
from the previous hour that we were
taking we were talking about extensions
of is is this fee when viewed as a 0 as
a function on 0 1 to the end to 0 1 so
this fee is dead F okay when you you
know but that F was not a polynomial
anything was just a function from 0 1 to
the end of 0 1 and we now need to come
up with an extension polynomial of that
function
other questions
what was an extension so I haven't oh so
I I think you're asking why why is why
is it enough to have an extension
polynomial no but maybe that too but I
guess it seems like it's the same kind
of size it's the picture you gave the
extension that seemed like those a lot
more of inputs yeah so right so we're we
are not going to use like so that
picture note no party is going to
materialize that whole picture so you're
right that picture like the polynomial
had this huge domain right the domain of
G is filled to the N that's a huge
domain so not even the prover is going
to like materialize that whole domain so
in order to apply the some check
protocol to a polynomial it's just
important that the proven verifier be
able to evaluate the polynomial ficient
lee at any desired point that doesn't
mean they have to evaluate at every
single possible input but the other
interpretation of your question is also
worth addressing so the reason it's
enough to compute the sum of an
extension polynomial of these
evaluations on the boolean input is an
extension polynomial by definition
agrees with the thing it's extending at
the boolean inputs so we want we really
care about this sum you know summing
fees values at the boolean inputs but an
extension is going to spit out the same
things on those boolean endless so by
replacing fie in the Sun with the
polynomial we're not changing the sum
yes that's essential
any other questions
so to summarize this protocol all we're
doing is replying the subject protocol
to an extension polynomial of this zero
one valued function fee but in order to
fully specify the protocol I have to
tell you like how exactly this extension
is defined to ensure that it's low
degree and the verifier can evaluate it
efficiently at a point and the way you
do this is a technique called
arithmetician so this is this is what
arithmetician does so it replaces the
boolean formula fee whose gates are
Endor and naught and it turns it into
what's called an arithmetic circuit so
an arithmetic circuit is a circuit with
whose gates are whose inputs are entries
of a finite field and whose gates
compute addition and multiplication over
the field and what this arithmetic
circuit is going to do the way we get it
is we replace each boolean gate a fee
with the multi-linear extension of the
function computed by that boolean gate
so let's see a picture of this so that's
that's what we've done here so so like
what is the multi linear extension of
the not function so not Maps 0 to 1 and
1 to 0 so there's a unique multi linear
polynomial that does the same thing and
that is just 1 minus the input this 1
minus 0 is 1 and 1 minus 1 is 0
yeah so yeah I will come to that but
basically when we turn this form and
this is what a formula is important when
we turn this formula into this
arithmetic circuit it turns out it's not
so hard to see that the degree of the
polynomial computed by this arithmetic
circuit is that most the size of the
formula so if if X 3 fed into many
different gates well each thing that
feeds into is contributing to the size s
of the formula so that gives us so we're
allowed to use a higher degree
Gnomeo here because the degree of this
is a we're going to let it be as big as
the size of this right so yeah so okay
so to dive into the weeds quickly so
I'll eyes pointing out that this fact is
not true about circuits it's you've
really using formulas here imagine like
the circuit that computes the end of n
bits by a binary tree of like fan and
two and gates sorry tree I'm not sure I
can actually come up with this online
yeah I think there's a very small
circuit for like the end of n bits like
his size yeah that's what I'm trying to
get ad with like it and end it so n
turns into multiplication so I'm trying
to do repeated squaring in the belief
yeah okay so yeah I'll try to come up
with this answer maybe this extra time
at the end but it's really important to
make sure that the degree of this is
that most the number of gates in the
formula it's important that it's a
formula is everything that's fan out
that seems right so that you can take
the yeah so I guess that's computing the
end of like one thing yeah it's a stupid
way to compute the dictator function
which just spits out the input and if
you were to rithmatist that circuit you
would get a very high degree polynomial
okay so what this transformation is
doing is it's replacing not X with 1
minus X it's replacing end of X Y with X
times y because end evaluates to true
only if both of its inputs are 1 and
this multi linear polynomial evaluates
to true at 0 1 valued inputs only if
both of them are 1 right if either one
of these is 0 its 0 and this is the
multi linear extension of or so you can
think about this off you can just
they're only for cases to check right so
it 0 maps to 0 and any any other 0 1
value stream maps to 1 so this
transformation is going gate by gate
through the formula and replacing the
the gate with the multi linear extension
so the not-gay turned into 1 minus the
input to the not gate times sorry n
turned into x right this this or gate
turned into this thing that sums its two
inputs and then subtracts the product so
this sum the two inclusive this that's
the transformation and it should be
clear I think by examining this that
this is indeed an extension polynomial
this this arithmetic circuit just
because like gate by gate as you work
your way through the formula the same
kind of thing is happening in the
polynomial world as long as your inputs
are boolean so let's actually see that
on an example so if you evaluate the
formula gate by gate on this example
like the not gate evaluates to 1 and
this arithmetic gate also evaluates to 1
so we the end gate evaluates to 1 plus
it's 1 times 1 and this times gate or at
one end 1 and this times gate is 1 times
1 so the same thing is happening on both
sides right that or gate evaluates to 1
and so does this - Kate that's computing
the multi-layer extension so just date
by gate through the whole circuit it's
preserving what what the formula is
doing this arithmetic circuit is
computing a polynomial
clear so arithmetician is one of the
most powerful ideas in complexity theory
it's a way to kind of go from boolean
functions which have nice
representations into kind of algebraic
encodings of those functions to
summarize this is a technique for
turning boolean formulas into arithmetic
circuits and yeah if you do so I guess I
can say a little bit about this facts so
if the formula has size s the degree of
the polynomial computed by this circuit
is at most s and that's true basically
because we use multi linear extensions
here so like for each gate in the
circuit like this end gate is the
product of two inputs and that that
product of two inputs is a multi linear
function so whatever the degree total
degree of this thing was feeding into
the end gate and this thing feeding into
the end gate the end gate itself is just
turning into the product of those two
things right so if you work through it
that's how you get to degree bounds you
know each date in this formula is kind
of contributing
and moreover this as much this is the
easiest thing to see the arithmetic
circuit can be evaluated any input in
time order s and that's because each
gate of the formula is turning into a
constant number of gates in the circuit
right so to like evaluate this or gate
was just one step here and here it's
like three steps because you do one
addition one multiplication and one
subtraction each field operation I'm
calling just one one unit questions
about arithmetician there's certainly
people in there it's out so the this
protocol for sharp set is from one for
now car off in the Isan there are dozens
of people in the room who can tell me
whether arithmetician hurt and hit it in
that paper leaver fight so there was a
sequence of works where these ideas were
developed and refined and built on and
you can
other questions
so no more questions then - we can
summarize so that the Sharps at protocol
simply applies the sum check protocol to
the polynomial G computed by this
arithmetic circuit the very end of the
protocol the verifier has to evaluate
this polynomial at a random point and it
can do it just gate by gate through the
circuit so to summarize the cost of the
protocol it's this is an N very
polynomial we're applying some check to
so there are n rounds the the degree of
the polynomial we're applying some check
to is s where s is the formula size so
this means that the total communication
and verify runtime turns out to be
bounded by s times n so note like even
for the verifier to even read the
formula takes time s so this is only a
factor and off from optimal and the
prover time and I didn't go into the
details of this before about how you
achieve this but the prover can be made
to run in time s times n times 2 to the
N and in some sense this is also optimal
certainly we do not know a faster
algorithm to even solve the problem than
about 2 to the N time actually s times 2
to the N time it's not clear how to
solve the problem other than more or
less for the prover to evaluate the
formula and every possible input there
are to the n inputs so that's that's the
protocol and up to like this factor n
here like every every party is running
optimally quickly
so that's the sharp stat protocol now
sharp sad is it's called a sharp P
complete problem exactly the definition
of that isn't isn't so important but
this is considered like a very big class
of problems
it's a powerful class and because we can
solve sharps AB you can actually solve
any problem in that class in fact it's
not too much harder to show and this was
your question from before I P equals P
space this is already like the technical
core of the reserve the following result
it's a famous result of Shamir building
on the LF can paper so any problem
solvable in polynomial space has an
interactive proof where the verifier
runs in polynomial time and the
technical core of that result is
actually the sharp side protocol ok so
that's a wonderful result you can ask is
this a practical result can we use it
for anything
and I think the answer is that it is not
a practical result and I'll explain why
at a moment the main reason being the
runtime of the prover so what's going on
here so you know I said that the prover
runtime in the sharp set protocol is
basically optimal because we can't even
solve the problem you don't know how to
solve the problem in less than 2 to the
end time and the prover is running in
close to 2 to the N time but in the real
world are people really solving problems
that take to to the end time to solve at
all I don't even think like Google's
cloud computer or whatever company you
know can really solve pspace-complete
problems if they're truly like
adversarial instances and large
instances so what we'd really like is to
apply these techniques to solve problems
that people can solve in the real world
and you can try to do this by kind of
taking your easy problem and turning it
into a sharp set instance and then
running the sharp stat protocol on that
sharp set instance that's like a crazy
way to try to solve your problem but you
could do it and if you try to do it
you'd run into this issue that the
prover would run in super polynomial
time even if the problem you started
with was very simple so in principle you
can take any problem solvable in
logarithmic space you can turn it into a
sharp
that instance and you can apply the
sharp set protocol to that sharp set
instance but the prover will still run
in super polynomial time on that sharp
set instance even if your original
problem is solvable in logarithmic space
which is okay so I'd you know I want to
be clear like you can't really improve
the sharp set protocol kind of on its
own terms because the problem takes time
to to the end to solve anyway even
without a guarantee of correctness but
what you can do is you can hope if you
started with an easy problem but one
that the verifier wants to outsource
anyway you can hope to do better than
what you would get by applying the sharp
set program you know to that easy
problem does that make sense so if you
start with the problem that's solvable
in log space you can turn it into a
sharp set instance where the number of
variables of the sharp site instance is
log squared n I'm not going to tell you
how to do it it's something like savages
theorem or something and but then if you
apply the sharp side protocol to that
that takes time to to the log squared n
which is super polynomial so we really
want like a more direct way to solve
easy problems right this this is a great
protocol but it only applies to a hard
problem so let me tell you what our new
goal is our new goal is captured by this
notion called doubly efficient
interactive cruise see what that means
in a second so what we really want is
they want the verifier to not do much
more work than just read the input so we
want a linear time verifier and we want
to prove or to run in polynomial time
so of course we can't even hope for this
if the problem we're outsourcing to the
prover is not solvable in polynomial
time but imagine the problem we're
outsourcing to the prover is solvable in
time into the fourth and the verifier
doesn't have the resources to run in
time n to the fourth this protocol will
be useful doubly efficient interactive
proof will let the verifier basically
just read the input that's it and the
prover will
still be efficient this is the sort of
thing we we actually care about in this
program this semester we don't want our
previous videos okay so I want to give
you a very clean example of a doubly
efficient interactive proof for a
problem
counting triangles which people actually
do care about and the main point of
showing you this protocol actually is
just to show you that the subject
protocol is like really useful I think
for a long time you know people thought
this is a beautiful protocol for sharp
sad but this is not a useful thing you
know the some check was the key to it
but some check isn't that useful
hopefully within one more slide you'll
appreciate just how powerful the subject
protocol is and it's also just kind of a
cute result ok so counting triangles our
input is the adjacency matrix of a graph
so that's an N by n matrix whose entries
are 0 1 so you know 1 represents there's
an edge between these two nodes and 0
there's no ledge ok so counting the
number of triangles in the graph is the
same as computing this sum ok so this is
saying you're summing over all triples
and nodes I J and K and asking is there
an edge between i J JK and I K that's
that's what it means for there to be a
triangle between I J and K they're all
connected to each other this 1/6 here is
just because there are 6 ways to order I
J and K you don't want to count the same
triangle six times
so the fastest known algorithm for this
problem much like in free vods protocol
runs in matrix multiplication time which
is currently not known to be N squared
it's bigger than that so I'm going to
give you an interactive proof for this
problem and would be doubly efficient so
the verifier will run in linear time
that is N squared time and the river
will run in polynomial time so this is
how it works we're the one tricky thing
here is we're not going to view the
input as an n by n matrix okay we're
going to view the input as a function on
to log n bits in the natural way but in
case you don't think it's natural to me
let me explain that so we're going to
interpret the first log n bits as
specifying a number I between 1 and N
and the second log in bits is specifying
a number J between 1 and N and we're
going to interpret a as a function as
spitting out just a IJ ok but the input
we're thinking of as you know bits
instead of indices
okay so now we have our input is no
longer an N by n matrix it's actually a
function on 0 1 to the 2 log N and
that's the kind of functions that we've
talked about taking low degree
extensions of so we're gonna let a
twiddle denote the multi linear
extension of that function and I'm going
to define this polynomial here so it's
just the multi linear extension of the
input evaluated at variables X Y times
the same thing but now with the
variables Y Z and times the variables X
so now like a twiddle has degree at most
one in each variable this thing has
degree at most two in each variable
because like each coordinate of X
appears twice how are we going to define
it so that this is the sum I want to
compute
another other questions at this point
there's nothing especially because city
like you've been like the complete
correct yeah yes quite a general
technique actually you can count like
arbitrary sub grass but it's just clean
us to talk about triangles how does the
upper bone using matrix whose education
scale that I don't I don't know
okay so the final protocol is we're just
going to apply the sum check protocol to
this polynomial so the point is that
this polynomial extends this function
here that we're trying to sum so this is
very similar to the Sharpe stat protocol
I mean basically the same thing as just
the polynomial were applying some check
to is different
appreciate this some chick but because
the [ __ ] teleport this algorithm is
running kind of much efficient it means
that they could use your other particle
at the beginning oh yeah yes so that's a
great question so because there is an
algorithm for the so the question was
can you solve this problem just using a
matrix multiplication protocol because
you can count triangles with matrix
multiplication the answer is you can but
in that protocol the mitchum application
protocol the prover had to send the
actual product matrix and that would be
N squared bits and the total
communication of this protocol is going
to be like order login
so this is um kind of the magical power
we see interaction buys you is it kind
of can force the verifier can force the
prover to materialize a bunch of values
without making the prove we actually
send those values to the verifier it
used something non interactive like free
rods protocol well free rods is great at
the verifies linear time but the prereqs
you have to send all of these values to
there
other questions
okay so yeah so again the protocol is
just apply some check to this three log
n very polynomial what are the costs so
because G has degree at most two in each
variable and there is only
logarithmically many variables the total
communication is only logarithmic the
verifier just has to evaluate the multi
linear extension of a at three points
and I mentioned in the last hour the
previous network that each of those
evaluations can be computed in linear
time so the verifier just runs in linear
time exactly as we wanted and the
provers runtime is not much more than
just what's required to compute this sum
in the first place in the naive manner
anyway I just mentioned if if you're
more clever about it you can actually
come up with a different protocol where
the prove our runs in matrix
multiplication time as well if you have
to change the protocol yeah its matrix
multiplication time if you just want to
solve the problem yeah
which is more than N squared so we're
saving the verifier time here
so this thing's gonna bog in this
problem to be terribly efficient yeah
yes but the communication is gonna blow
up to a polynomial but the polynomial
can be arbitrarily small as long as your
constants of law
you don't wonder the log in your way big
comfy to the that's right or some subset
of the field to this so you can play
games with this if you wanted to and
this to play these games to trade off
between rounds and communication you no
longer work / 0 1 to the L you work over
some other products
you said you can't reduce the reverse
yeah so the key to that is to use a
non-trivial an optimal interactive proof
for matrix multiplication so free
Broad's protocol again is optimal in a
certain sense because the verifier is
linear time but to prove we actually
have to send the product matrix and
there's a known interactive proof for
matrix multiplication where if you don't
actually care about the product matrix
there are ways to avoid the prove we're
actually sending and explicitly so I
probably want to leave it at that unless
there happens to be lots of extra time
at the end but then you don't do
something please know you still use some
check but so basically you replace free
vod's protocol with a sum check based
interactive proof for matrix
multiplication and it's a non trivial I
mean it's my protocol so I don't want to
talk it up too much but I like it
can you repeat what did you say where
the parameters if you wanted to make it
constantly yeah so I think it should be
so if you interpret rather than viewing
a as a function from like to log n bits
to 0 1 or the field if you instead you a
si a function from you know 0 1 up to n
to the 1/4 by 0 1 up to n the 1/4 and
you do that four times
you can still define low degree
extensions of that you know that
function which is now only like a four
very function or a period or whatever
and but your communication is going to
grow like n to the 1/4 what's happening
is as you try to drive the number of
variables down you blow up the degree of
the extension so within some check
you're cutting down the number of rounds
but increasing the amount of the degree
of the polynomial is that the progress
to send in each round the best remark on
central I believe so this one we're see
like we're doing I think so I know that
Roth bloom and gold Reich have some
recent work on you know like interactive
proofs for simple problems and I'm not
sure if they might have an interesting
result in there but if I had to guess
this is actually does increases the
running time
[Music]
correct but in a doubly efficient
interactive proof we just required a
linear time verifier so as long as these
polynomials are at most degree n and all
of them will be we're not by hiding the
doubly efficient interactive proof
property but you might be driving your
communication up closer and closer to
linear
yeah well it's possible that the
problems just solvable in linear time
and then there's no communication and
login and constant coefficient is
positive I don't think we know anything
like that people will study settings
interactive proofs with restricted
verifiers like a verifier that's be a
streaming algorithm and in that setting
we know that this protocol is optimal in
some sense or close to optimal but yeah
for general verifiers where computation
is the bottleneck obviously we
so maybe it's not gonna let set up to
the verify should run in something no
time and it's kind of like this top we
first thing something similar to I would
have to think about that yeah I'll take
that offline
and your questions
[Applause]
okay so anyway I think the main point
I'm trying to convey here is just that a
lot of problems even problem people
really care about in the real world
turnout they can be phrased often in
non-trivial ways as just a big sum and
oftentimes each term of the sum agrees
with some low degree polynomial and if
you have that situation then as long as
the verifier can evaluate that
polynomial efficiently at around the
point just apply some check to it and
you'd be surprised how far that can get
you okay
all right so I want to talk about
general purpose W efficient interactive
proofs and from now on I can necessarily
only be quite sketchy and how they work
but I want to tell you the main results
because you know these are the frontiers
both for open research directions and
just the things people are using in
practice now a lot so what do I mean by
a general purpose W efficient interact
the proof well ideally we would like and
interact the proofs that kind of apply
not just to counting triangles or matrix
multiplication but you can kind of apply
them to any problem so the first general
purpose W interact W efficient
interactive proof I want to tell you
about is a result by goldwasser Klein
and Ralph Blume from 2008 and this a it
applies to any problem but it's only
efficient it's only W efficient if the
problem is solvable by a parallel
algorithm so let me explain so general
purpose proof systems
ideally work as follows so you'd like
you know the verifier to be able to say
here's a computer program I want the
prover to run on my data and the way
these true systems tend to work is the
first thing they do is they say well
computer programs I don't really know
how to deal with them I'm going to turn
the computer program into some other
representation of the computation which
is easier for me to deal with and
normally this kind of representation is
an arithmetic circuit or something
similar so we already saw arithmetic
circuits for in the sharp stat protocol
so you basically already seen this sort
of thing we don't like boolean formulas
so we turn them into a arithmetic
circuit computing a low degree
polynomial so typically we call these
kind of programs - circuit
transformations we call them like the
front end of the system and then we
design the interactive proof to work on
the circuit so we make sure the prover
actually correctly evaluated the circuit
gate by gate
so that's how the G care protocol works
so it operates on a circuit an
arithmetic circuit and the protocol will
be efficient as long as the circuit has
low depth and it's just a fax that I
won't go into any detail about that if
your computer program actually
implements an efficient parallel
algorithm then the circuit that comes
out of the front end can be made low
depth so like the depth of the circuit
is like the number of sequential steps
that the parallel algorithm runs for
roughly speaking so the G carry protocol
just tries to verify that the prover
correctly evaluated the circuit gate by
date and I'm just gonna give you like a
caricature of how it works
I can't obviously can't give full
details about it so I would like to
compare it to like the world's dumbest
proof so the world's dumbest proof I
think would work as follows at least the
most convenient dumb proof so the dumb
proof would start by the prover just
saying hey this is the output value of
the circuit so here's the output gate
this is what it evaluated to now the
verifier doesn't believe it so the
prover can say well look I'll prove to
you that this output gate was evaluated
correctly here are the inputs to the
output gate good check check for
yourself like I'm telling you the truth
about these inputs so just make sure
that the value of the appliquéd like is
actually the sum of these two infants if
I could do that but then the verify was
like well I obviously if I didn't
believe you about the Applegate I don't
believe you about these things so
previous like no problem I'll send you
the values of all the gates feeding into
those things and they can keep doing
this until eventually the prover you
know gets to the input level and the
verifier sees the input explicitly so
the verifier can just check you know
does what the proof is saying the input
is actually agree with the true input
so we're done right so the problem of
course here is that this is as expensive
even in just the communication much less
the verifier time as just the verifier
evaluating the circuit herself so what
we really need is a way to kind of do
this sort of walking from the output to
the input level without actually having
the prover materialize all the
intermediate gate values to the to the
verifier
so that's what the GTR protocol does and
I can't really give much more detail
than that in this talk but basically
what they do is so first the the prover
sends the claimed output of the circuit
and then they invoke the sum check
protocol applying it to like a very
cleverly chosen polynomial and at the
end of that subject protocol the prover
is basically forced to make a claim
about the value of that polynomial at a
random point and because of the way that
polynomial defined it's like turns out
to be defined in terms of the gate
values at this layer of the circuit
feeding into the output you know that is
implicitly the proof or making a claim
about the gate values at this level but
it's the subject protocol only has
logarithmic communication just somehow
like and conceptually speaking the same
thing happened in the dumb proof as in
the gkr protocol but in the GTR protocol
we've avoided the need for the prover to
actually send all of the claim
gate values at this layer to the to the
verify that this layer there only two
good values but eventually you're going
to get to a really wide layer and that's
where the savings really come in okay so
hopefully this is making a little bit of
sense giving you some idea of what's
going on to summarize like at the end of
this first invocation of the subject
protocol the prover and verifier have
reduced a claim about the output gate to
the circuit to a claim about the gates
feeding into the output in the sense
that if the verifier believes the claim
about these gates it's safe for the
verifier to believe the claim about
these games yeah
but they did this somehow without the
proof we're actually sending all of all
of these gates to the verifier and then
just do this round by round kind of
reducing a claim about these gates will
clean up these gates until they
eventually get to the input and when
they get to the input layer what the
prover has actually done is write the
protocol you know much the way we
interpreted the n-by-n adjacency matrix
as a in the triangle protocol as a
function on two log n bits
the GTR protocol interprets the input as
a function on log n bits in the same way
exactly the same way and this final
claim that the prover makes at the end
of the GTR protocol is just to claim
about the multi linear extension of that
function at or evaluated a random point
and we've already discussed that
verifier can check that claim in linear
time the probability of mistake okay
tend approval really food fool you if
the verifier
when you send the two values to the top
choose this one and continue just no
pull two with this one and now pull to
me this one right so that's the magic so
what's really happening in this protocol
is like that I didn't mean to suggest
that the prover is actually sending
actual gate values to the verifier in
the subject protocol what you're dealing
with is really low degree polynomials
that like extends that are extensions of
the gate values when interpreted as
functions on on bits in the way I was
talking about here and with the triangle
protocol so what when I say that the
prover is making a claim about the value
of these gates what I really mean is
it's making the proof the computation is
equivalent to doing the whole circuit
but if you choose just one run so here's
the problem so the prover can set send
like the correct values for like every
gate but one here yes okay so at this
layer right yeah so so the issue is that
the soundness error will be consumed so
at this layer when there are literally
two gates the error the sound of server
is like this is a half but eventually
you're going to this protocol really
only gets interesting when the layers
gets wide yeah so so like you know
imagine if this was a really wide layer
the the prover kalaiy about like just
one gate value and there's very little
chance to verify were detected so then
you'd have to try to repeat the protocol
like an insane number of times to drive
the cenicero down
it sounds like the probability of
success will be 1 1 over n and where n
is like a circuit size the second size
the whole time in the deficit we'll
think of it as log n they need to each
time you have a probability of success
of no because it is half only comes in
when there are like two gates at the
layer but if if a layer had a billion
gates in it and the provers sent like
all the right values but 1 it can still
mess up the output of the circuit but
there's like almost no chance the
verifier will pick up on it so this is
the magic of low degree polynomials is
they amplify even those tiny errors into
very easily detectable things and that's
the obviously I mean maybe this overview
is can only be so useful without going
into the details
I guess I don't miss any modeling
verified
[Music]
correct so yeah so yeah so within the
guts of the g'kar protocol you there are
you have to use functions that somehow
encode the wiring pattern of the circuit
right that's like the the protocol
obviously has to do something has to
depend on the circuit in some way
otherwise how are you making sure the
prover is dealing with your circuit and
what's happened to avoid the verifier
materializing the whole circuit what you
need is that these functions that we
call them wiring predicates that encode
the wiring of the circuit if you take
low degree extension of those functions
the verifier can evaluate that low
degree extension efficiently and there's
not too much I can really say about this
other than like if your circuit is log
space uniform then this this all works
out very nicely and the verifier doesn't
need to materialize the whole circuit
yeah it's just some totally wild
ridiculous circuit then there you know
there's it's hopeless like for the
verifier to even like really know what
circuit you're dealing with the verifier
is going to have to look at the whole
circuit like how are you even going to
write down an arbitrarily an arbitrary
circuit you're going to have to write
down all the wires
correct now that that but that linear
step can happen in pre-processing
because it doesn't depend on the input
but yeah the fact of the matter is if
you don't want the verifier to at some
point have to spend time linear in the
size of the circuit you need your
circuit to have a succinct implicit
representation right otherwise there's
no way to even specify the circuit
your swing is a function that describes
this right yeah so correct and g'kar is
original paper they showed that you know
for any log space uniform circuit
meaning there's a log space algorithm
that you know can kind of take as input
like a label of a wire and tell you what
gate it's connecting or something like
that then in fact none of this is an
issue
there's basically like a a efficient
program that is represents the circuit
in some way and that's enough to render
g-girl without that verifier
materializing
[Music]
yes so in the pre-processing phase all
the verifier needs to do is evaluate
these low degree extensions of these
wiring predicates at a random point and
that's enough then it can throw away the
circuit and go ahead with the GK
I'd like to I guess I need to move on
since I'm just about out of time so
hopefully that gives you some sense just
some sense of how it works
so this protocol is efficient for the
verifier as long as the depth of the
circuit isn't too big right so there was
communication here between the proven
verifier for each layer of the circuit
so we we need the depth of the circuit
to be small for the verifier to be
efficient one nice thing about this
protocol is we've we've now achieved
approver that runs in time linear in the
size of the circuit so this is the
outcome of a long sequence of works and
the truly linear and the size of the
circuit runtime was achieved just this
year okay so I want to briefly mention
the state-of-the-art general-purpose
interactive proof together this in this
in this model with um I don't even like
what we did today like that even come up
something so the circuit is defined over
the field like yeah so the GTR protocol
applies to an arithmetic circuit
well I guess it depends what you mean by
practice
so we're tomorrow there will be lots of
talks on succinct arguments and it's now
known how to combine the GTR protocol
with cryptography to get a succinct
argument and maybe at some points not
too far in the future people will decide
that that argument has I mean it's like
competitive with all these other
succinct arguments that people are using
some of them in practice various ways
and for specific problems like counting
triangles and stuff if people really
were doing that and that's what they
cared about I mean that some check
protocol for counting triangles really
is efficient enough for practical use
that doesn't mean people have decided to
use it
okay so I hope I have time to tell you
this last result okay so what we would
really want is the following so if the
verifier asks the prove are to run some
program on her data we really want the
prover of the verifier to not do much
more work than read the input and the
prover shouldn't do much more work than
run the program so I define doubly
efficient interactive crews to just say
the prover should run in polynomial time
but really we want the prove or to not
do much more work than the bare minimum
that could possibly have to do which is
run the program right so we really want
that if the prover runs if the program
runs in time T and space s the prover
runs in time as close to linear and T as
possible in space as close to linear and
s as possible the GK our protocol comes
close to achieving this at least for
parallelizable programs but not in
general so there's a very nice recent
result that comes close to achieving the
best we can hope to achieve which is not
this unfortunately so for this you you
actually need an argument system which
you'll hear about tomorrow so what the
key issue is the following
it's that ipo's is contained in P space
so that is any interactive proof with a
very efficient verifier means that the
problem the interactive proof solves can
actually be solved in small space
it what's in your city and is the input
size so and W efficient interactive
proofs we want the verified around the
time linear and then okay so this result
this called the easy direction of IP
equals P space it says any efficient
interactive proof means the problem is
solvable in small space tell you that
you actually can't hope for this to
occur sorry the issue is not the provers
runtime it's the verifier running in
linear time if your problem just
requires cubic space to solve you cannot
hope for a linear time verifier in the
interactive does that make sense
so what what can we hope for so the best
we can hope for is basically if if the
problem is solvable in like linear space
or you know rudin space or into the
one-third space then we can hope for all
of this so so roth bloom Rango drop them
in roth bloom in 2016 came up with a
protocol that very nearly achieves this
crypto program it's a really really nice
nice result and it says the following so
if F is a problem solvable in time T and
space s then okay so sorry for the
technicality but we need epsilon to be
an arbitrarily small constant and then
we can get the verifier to run in time
that's basically linear plus this power
of T but it's like an arbitrarily small
power of T so you can almost ignore it
and then a polynomial a fixed polynomial
in the space complexity this is a lot of
notation to follow us simplify it in a
moment and then the prover runs in time
nearly linear in T so he's off by just
this on epsilon factor in the exponent
okay so here's I think the right way to
think about it imagine that T was some
polynomial in N say n to the fourth and
s was I don't know end of the one tenth
then we would have a doubly efficient
interactive process
the verifier would run in linear time
the prover would run in polynomial time
and in fact the prover is running in
time very close to just what the program
runs in yeah
what is the trait for choosing
excellence
yeah the trade-off is just the number of
rounds is one over epsilon sorry
exponential mano gradual so I think if
you allowed a super constant number of
rounds you can actually make epsilon sub
constant fill this typing log X or love
DS or valgus I'll get back to you on
that
I think it's hiding log T's
does epsilon affect the degree of s in
the poly so it seems like people are
understanding the gist of the result and
I don't know off the top of my head
nitty-gritty details about various
dependencies yeah but basically this
works for bounded polynomial space
algorithms and the prover is about as
efficient as you could hope for okay
great so I guess I can close with open
questions and now they won't kill me so
obviously since since RRR is kind of the
state of the art if you're looking for
generality the state of the art W
efficient interactive proof system there
are nice questions about just improving
the quantitative nature of our you know
does the number of rounds really need to
be exponential in 1 over this epsilon
parameter canopy polynomial do you
really need this T to the epsilon things
like that so these are technical
questions but this is such a central
question you know how for what problems
come and get W efficient interactive
proofs that I think these are really
important there's also a very nice
question about what's called batch
verification of NP so here's here's the
situation interact the proofs themselves
cannot be what's called succinct so this
means if you're trying to verify an
arbitrary NP relation unless something
crazy happens that we don't believe
should possibly happen you can't really
do better than just having the prove
ourselves to the verifier so to get
succinct protocols you need to use
cryptography and we're going to hear
about that tomorrow but what you can't
hope to do is the following say I give
you K instances of the same NP problem
and ask you so this is like an
amortization question and say you know
prove er hey convinced me that each one
of these K instances is a yes instance
so you could at least hope for like the
communication and the verifier run time
to grow sublease of linearly with k and
it's not known if you can do this or not
so the state-of-the-art result also by
RRR
gives a protocol like this for you P
which is like a subclass of NP but it's
not all of NP so I have one parting
thought I promise it's 30 seconds so in
this talk we've seen some fundamental
limitations and interactive proofs so I
mentioned like two slides ago like you
just cannot have an a an interactive
proof with a linear time verifier for
very space intensive problems they
cannot be succinct they're interactive
in the name which means that which makes
them unsuitable for some applications
they're not publicly verifiable so all
these things are inherent to interactive
proofs so you might be in this room
thinking well why should I pay attention
to interactive proofs I need these
properties I need to sickness I need
non-interactive and I just wanted I
mentioned it already but I want to be
clear like these limitations can be
addressed by combining interactive
proofs with cryptography I think we're
going to hear a little bit about this or
related techniques tomorrow and there
are many practically relevant open
questions about how best to combine
interactive proof through that I won't
describe but that's an entire research
program that I think is really exciting
to focus on this semester for anyone
who's
I just wonder whether the our protocol
is it like this is the core of the
protocols I'm going to GK or is it D
care with so I can say it doesn't make
use of the some Czech protocol somewhere
in its guts but I deviates in many ways
no I mean publicly verifiable is like
the prover you know just publishes a
proof and I just for the setting to make
the most sense the proof is just a fixed
string so can't even be interactive now
anyone in the world can come and check
the proof so something could be non
interactive and not publicly verifiable
I don't really know how anything could
be interactive in publicly
we're the graphic assumptions like I
mean you need we're talking about preach
can we have like Public Liability
so I guess to summarize they're not
necessarily the same thing if there's
some trusted source of randomness
that is the statement of combining
interactive food with with photography
well if you take a tog Rafi to mean you
know the precise complexity that if you
break this it's equivalent to the clear
little something that we know what's the
complexity then it's the same what's the
difference it's the same series it's
another logarithm yeah so I think you're
asking about the difference I think
correct me if I'm misunderstanding
between interactive proofs which have to
be statistically secure so in the matter
how hard the prover works to try to
trick the verifier improver will fail
with high probability right so versus
what are caught argument systems which
we're gonna hear about tomorrow where
you can have something like the
following like if the prover breaks your
crypto system then he can trick the
verifier so everything I say here about
limitations of interactive proofs there
they all need these limitations only
come up if if it's statistically secure
which is what interactive proof refers
[Applause]